WE START WITH PROTESTS SPREADING
RAPIDLY AND INTENSELY ACROSS
CHINA.
THOUSANDS OF DEMONSTRATORS ARE
ANGRY WITH COVID LOCKDOWNS, MANY
CALLING FOR DEMOCRACY AND
POLITICAL FREEDOMS AND AN END TO
PRESIDENT XI JINPING'S REGIME.
POLICE HAVE RESPONDED TO THE
UNREST WITH BRUTALITY, CHAOTIC
SCENES OF PROTESTERS BEING
DRAGGED, SHOVED AND BEATEN.
LOOK AT BBC REPORTER ED LAWRENCE
BEING TAKEN INTO CUSTODY IN
SHANGHAI.
AGAIN THAT IS A JOURNALIST, LOOK
AT WHAT POLICE ARE DOING TO HIM,
TAKING HIM INTO CUSTODY.
THE BBC SAID LAWRENCE WAS KICKED
AND HANDCUFFED FOR HOURS BEFORE
BEING RELEASED.
SELENA WANG IS LIVE IN BEIJING
FOR CNN THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR REPORTING ON
THIS.
THIS IS DEEPLY PERSONAL TO SO
MANY IN CHINA.
HOW DIFFERENT IS THIS FROM WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IN AT LEAST THE LAST
DECADE OR SO?
IT SEEMS THIS TIME IS DIFFERENT.
>> Reporter: THIS IS
UNPRECEDENTED, SINCE XI JINPING
TOOK POWER.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS SURREAL
AND UNBELIEVABLE.
LAST NIGHT I WAS THERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PROTEST IN THE
CAPITAL OF CHINA, TALKING ABOUT
A COUNTRY WHERE IT IS EXTREMELY
DANGEROUS TO PUBLICALLY
CRITICIZE THE PARTY, ESPECIALLY
XI HIMSELF, YOU RISK JAIL TIME
OR WORSE.
AND LAST NIGHT IN BEIJING THEY
WERE CHANTING OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, WE DON'T WANT COVID TESTS
WE WANT FREEDOM.
SOME SHOUTING FOR FREEDOM OF
SPEECH, HUMAN RIGHTS.
MANY PEOPLE HOLDING WHITE PAPER
IN THEIR HANDS, A SIGN OF
SOLIDARITY AGAINST CENSORSHIP.
I TALKED TO A PROTESTER WHO TOLD
ME HE MOTORCYCLED AND BIKED MORE
THAN AN HOUR TO GET TO THE
SCENE.
WHEN ASKED HOW HE WAS FEELING,
WHICH IS A WHAT HE TOLD ME.
>> Translator: I'M OVERWHELMED.
EVERYONE SHOULD BE HERE.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO VOICE THEIR
OPINIONS BUT I HOPE THEY CAN
STAND WITH US.
>> Reporter: AND I CANNOT
OVEREMPHASIZE HOW RARE IT IS TO
HAVE SOMEONE SPEAK TO CNN
MASKLESS IN PUBLIC, SHOWS HOW
DETERMINED THEY ARE FOR THEIR
VOICES TO BE HEARD.
AFTER 2:00 A.M. MORE POLICE
FILED IN, FORCING US TO
DISPERSE, WE SAW THE VIDEOS OF
VIOLENCE IN SHANGHAI BUT WHAT I
WITNESSED YESTERDAY WAS AT LEAST
PEACEFUL.
>> IT IS DANGEROUS, THEY'RE
OBVIOUSLY PUTTING THEIR SAFETY
ON THE LINES THERE.
POPPY ASKED THE QUESTION, WHAT
HAPPENED THIS TIME.
BUT DO YOU THINK THIS WILL BE
EFFECTIVE THIS TIME?
>> Reporter: WELL, THESE PEOPLE
ARE EXTREMELY DETERMINED, BUT
THIS IS ALSO EXTREMELY DANGEROUS
AND THE SECURITY PRESENCE IS
HUGE.
I'M ABOUT TO DRIVE OUT RIGHT
AFTER THIS TO GO BACK TO THE
PLACE WE WERE, AND I'M EXPECTING
TO SEE ROWS OF POLICE CARS
THERE.
WHAT PUSHED PEOPLE PAST THEIR
BREAKING POINT THIS POINT WAS SO
HEARTBREAKING.
A FIRE THAT BROKE OUT THAT
KILLED AT LEAST TEN PEOPLE AND
VIDEOS OF THE SCENE INDICATED
THAT COVID RESTRICTIONS
PREVENTED VICTIMS FROM GETTING
HELP WITH THE COMPOUND ENTRANCE
BLOCKED BY THE FENCES AND METAL
BARRIERS USED IN COVID
LOCKDOWNS.
YOU CAN SEE FLAMES COMING FROM
THE BUILDING, NO WATER ABLE TO
REACH THEM.
IT TRIGGERED PEOPLE'S WORST
NIGHTMARES, THE IDEA THAT ANY
ONE OF US CAN BE TRAPPED IN A
BUILDING WHILE FIRE IS RANGING,
UNABLE TO GET HELP.
>>> FOR MORE I WANT TO BRING IN
CHIEF NATIONAL SECURITY
CORRESPONDENT JIM SCIUTTO IN
WASHINGTON.
THERE HAVE BEEN SIGNS OF
DISSENT, BUT DO YOU THINK THE
NEW WAVE OF ANGER IS POSING A
BIGGER CHALLENGE FOR XI
JINPING'S GOVERNMENT.
>> IT IS POSTING A CHALLENGE,
THE QUESTION IS HOW BIG OF A
CHALLENGE THIS IS A GOVERNMENT
THAT BUILT A SECURITY APPARATUS
FOR TWO DECADES FOR THIS KIND OF
THING.
PROTESTS HAPPEN IN CHINA, A
COUNTRY OF MORE THAN A BILLION
AND A HALF PEOPLE BUT THOSE ARE
LOCAL.
THIS IS NATIONAL.
AND IT'S AFFECTING THE BIGGEST,
MOST POWERFUL CITIES, BEIJING,
SHANGH
SHANGHAI, WUHAN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE PROTESTS,
THEY'RE NOT SMALL AND ISOLATED,
OFTEN INVOLVING HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE OUT IN PUBLIC PLACES WITH
THEIR MASKS OFF, ALLOWS THEM TO
BE EASILY IDENTIFIED, THAT'S AN
ACT OF COURAGE IN THIS COUNTRY.
THIS IS A COUNTRY THAT TRACKS
EVERY ACT OF DISSENT AND KNOWS
WHO YOU ARE AND PUNISHES THOSE
PEOPLE.
IT'S AN ENORMOUS RISK TO DO WHAT
THESE PEOPLE ARE DOING TO
CHALLENGE THE GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT XI
JINPING IS NOTICING.
THEY'RE NOT JUST SAYING I HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH CHINA'S COVID
POLICY THEY'RE MENTIONING XI
JINPING BY NAME AND FREEDOMS BY
NAME.
LISTEN TO THIS PARTICULAR POINT
IN THE SOUTH.
LISTEN TO WHAT THE PROTESTERS
ARE SAYING HERE.
WE'LL PLAY THE CLIP.
THEY'RE SAYING NO TO LOCKDOWNS,
YES TO FREEDOMS.
THEY MENTION FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS, THEY MENTION FREEDOM OF
SPEECH, THEY MENTION FREEDOM OF
ACTION.
THESE ARE THINGS EXPLICITLY
FORBIDDEN IN CHINA, KAITLAN.
THAT'S A BROADER CRITICISM THAN
SAYING WE'RE SICK OF THE COVID
RESTRICTIONS.
>> THIS COMES AS XI HAS GOTTEN
HIS THIRD TERM IN POWER.
WHAT ARE YOU WATCHING TO SEE AND
HOW THE GOVERNMENT IS RESPONDING
TO THESE SEPARATE FACTIONS AND
PROTESTS COMING TOGETHER UNDER
THIS PUSHING BACK AGAINST THE
COVID RESTRICTIONS.
>> IT'S A GOOD QUESTION AND THEY
ARE RESPONDING BY TWEAKING.
WE HEARD TODAY -- SELINA WANG
MENTIONED THIS, THIS IS THE
MOMENT THAT STARTED THIS, YOU
HAD A FIRE AT AN APARTMENT
BUILDING.
THERE'S THE FIRE HOSE.
THE REASON THE FIREMEN COULD NOT
GET TO THE BUILDING IS BECAUSE
OF COVID RESTRICTIONS.
THERE WERE BARRIERS AROUND THE
BUILDING.
THEY'RE SO FAR AWAY, THE FIRE
CAN'T REACH THE FLAMES.
THEY HAVE SINCE TWEAKED SOME OF
THOSE POLICIES, NO LONGER FOR
INSTANCE LOCKING THE DOORS TO
APARTMENT COMPLEXES SO IN THE
EVEN OF A FIRE, FIREMEN CAN GET
IN THERE.
THOSE ARE TWEAKS.
WHEN COVID CASES WENT UP AGAIN,
THEY HAD TO REIMPOSE MANY
RESTRICTIONS THERE.
TO THIS POINT, KAITLAN, CHINA'S
COVID POLICY IS A FAILURE, THEIR
VACCINES LARGELY DON'T WORK,
PEOPLE ARE STILL GETTING
INFECTED.
ONE MOMENT THAT I WAS TOLD WAS
POWERFUL FOR THE CHINESE PEOPLE.
THEY'VE BEEN WATCHING THE WORLD
CUP.
THEY SEE MASKLESS CROWDS IN
QATAR, CHEERING FOR THEIR TEAMS.
CHINA IS STILL BEHIND MASKS.
IT'S NOT JUST THE DEVELOPING
WORLD THAT SEEMS TO HAVE PUT
COVID BEHIND IT, CHINA HAS NOT,
THAT'S CAUSING FRUSTRATION
THERE.
CHINA HAS AN ENORMOUS SECURITY
APPARATUS, THEY'LL CRACK DOWN
AND CRACK DOWN HARD.
>> WE'LL BE WATCHING.
THANK YOU.
THESE PROTESTS ARE A GLIMPSE OF
THE CHINESE PEOPLE STANDING UP
TO THE COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT,
AND DARING TO OPENLY CALL FOR
THE REMOVAL OF ISSUING THING.
HERE IS WHY SOME EXPERTS ARE
SAYING THAT IS UNUSUAL.
>> CHINA HAS OFTEN ALLOWED
PROTESTS, PEOPLE HAVE THE
MISTAKEN IMPRESSION THAT THEY
ALLOW NO PROTESTS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PROTESTS,
BUT THEY ARE ON SPECIFIC LOCAL
ISSUES.
FOOD SHORTAGES, LOCAL
PRODUCTION, SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
BUT WHAT IS EXTRAORDINARY ABOUT
THIS ONE IS THAT THEY ARE
ALLOWING PROTESTS IN WHICH
PEOPLE ARE TALKING MORE
GENERALLY ABOUT THE COMMUNIST
PARTY RULE, AS YOU SAY.
NO TO COVID LOCKDOWN, YES TO
FREEDOM.
THERE HAVE EVEN BEEN SOME OF
THOSE SHANGHAI PROTESTERS WHO
HAVE SAID SHE JINPING RESIGN,
THINGS LIKE THAT.
THAT IS COMPLETELY UNUSUAL.
IT IS UNPRECEDENTED, AND FOR IT
TO BE HAPPENING IN SHANGHAI, AT
XINHUA UNIVERSITY, THE
UNIVERSITY THAT SHE JINPING
WENT TO WHEN HE GOT HIS
CHEMICAL ENGINEERING DEGREE IN
THE 70S, THAT IS WHAT MAKES
THIS QUITE UNUSUAL.
>> IN CHINA, I DOUBT THAT WE
HAVE THE SITUATION THAT WE ARE
GOING TO SEE AN OVERTHROW OF
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY AND
LEADERSHIP.
THE CHINESE SECURITY SERVICES
LIKE ALL INTELLIGENCE SERVICE
SERVES AND --
TRY TO SPEND A LOT OF TIME
TRYING TO PENETRATE THESE
GROUPS, TO HAVE SPIES KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE UP TO.
I DO NOT THINK WE ARE GOING TO
SEE THE CLAPS OF THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT ANYTIME SOON.
>> THE PUBLIC PROTESTS AND NEWS
OF RISING COVID CASES HAVE
RATTLED THE FINANCIAL MARKETS.
BOTH HE --
TOOK MAJOR BLOWS AND THE
CHINESE ALSO PLUNGED AGAINST
U.S. DOLLAR.